we went to a sushi restaurant and I
noticed the Philadelphia roll was 15 but
you could get a salmon roll for nine so
they're charging six dollars just to put
cream cheese on the inside of the Roll
that doesn't make any sense I wonder if
I could just get cream cheese on the
side and I asked can I get a salmon roll
and just get cream cheese on the side
like how much is the cream cheese I
think I was like I've never been asked
that before yeah you're like a dollar
and I'm like okay cool a dollar so he
brings the cream cheese and brings the
rolls I just take the cream cheese and
put it on the top of the Roll oh it's
the same thing the exact same thing as a
five dollars